hi guys today i want to talk about seek
help uh and the benefits that go
beyond just the thyroid but i will say
that
a high quality sea kelp that is grown in
an
ocean that is clean is really beneficial
for the thyroid
the thyroid needs iodine to make its
hormones so when you see
like the t4 t3 the numbers three or four
represent the number of iodine molecules
that actually make that hormone but
iodine
goes beyond just the thyroid it's really
beneficial
in balancing your estrogen so if a woman
has too much estrogen
they might develop ovarian cysts
fibrocystic breast
problems and they take iodine that can
help balance estrogen dominance
so it's really good for that number two
enhances your iq
your cognitive performance especially in
a growing child
and if you're pregnant definitely take
seek help to get that iodine
because a lack of iodine will not only
reduce that iq
but actually the baby could come out
with a smaller brain so it's
really important in the growing brain as
well as your
growth in general you're going to end up
being shorter if you don't have enough
iodine
number three it has 10 times the calcium
than milk we all know a lot of the
problems with milk with the hormones and
what the cows eat
but sea kelp is a good source of calcium
before there's a lot of other nutrients
in sea kelp
magnesium manganese potassium
iron zinc which is very very important
vitamin c
and some of the b vitamins all right
number five
fucoidin this is a phytochemical which
has
some really powerful anti-cancer effects
it's an antioxidant it has
anti-inflammatory properties
and that benefit alone is quite amazing
number six
vanadium this is a trace mineral you
don't need it in large amounts
you need in smaller amounts that helps
your blood sugars okay
insulin resistance in fact all of the
trace minerals
are in sea kelp but it just so happens
that iodine seems to be the one that's
concentrated the most
so sea kelp or seaweed will concentrate
iodine from the sea water by
30 000 times so it's a super
concentrated iodine source as a
plant-based source so your body can
actually really utilize that very easily
so you don't need a lot of it you just
need a little bit of it
and i would recommend taking it in the
morning when you wake up not before you
go to bed because
it can give you too much energy and
lastly sea kelp actually contains amino
acids
now of course you'd have to consume a
certain amount of seaweed which
rarely people will do that because
they're just doing small amounts or
milligrams
so you're not going to get any
significant amount of amino acids but
just realize there are amino acids in
this product so we have
amino acids trace minerals minerals
vitamins phytonutrients it's just a
really good sea vegetable
that has benefits that go way beyond
just thyroid support
thanks for watching hey if you're liking
this content
please subscribe now and i will actually
keep you updated on future videos